[Music]
finally
unvetsy feels a little less alone
for years the art historian has tried to
challenge the way belgium deals with its
colonial past
now she's among thousands calling for
the removal of all monuments
of the country's longest serving monarch
the man who headed up
a brutal colonial regime in what is now
the democratic republic of congo
king leopold ii
we all know that those statues have a
symbolic power
and i'm totally convinced that for some
people
they are they don't want us to
demonstrate or they
don't want people to demonstrate and to
say stop
with these statues not because they want
to keep those statues there
they want to keep us in our statues of
inferiority angvetsi was born in belgium
but had to fight racism all her life
she struggled to forge a career in the
arts facing many rejections
now she has opened her own gallery that
spotlights the work of black artists
because the racism here is um
very subtle and this is what
makes makes it so dangerous
and so harmful to there are so many
examples like uh
if you're looking for an apartment you
have to say on the phone yeah but you
know
don't waste my time i'm black ah maybe
it's not oh maybe you're right the
apartment has already been
has already been taken the racism in
belgium however is not only fueled by a
false image of the colonial era
believes her colleague leopold's legacy
also reveals
vital interests i think the most
vulnerable spot is the wealth
how belgian enterprise how benjamin
families
got rich thanks to uh
thanks to congo and congo really helped
belgium to become
a state statues of leopold ii
like this one in the seaside resort of
ostend are everywhere
but there is no mention that his lavish
public spending
was financed by congolese robber and no
mention
of the millions of congolese people
killed in the process
instead the official website directs
tourists to a walking tour
highlighting how the king's achievements
bolstered the town's prestige
since the protests started a number of
statues and busts have been taken down
but authorities are busy restoring
others this history professor thinks
that sends the wrong message
the main problem of belgium though and
this is again a difference with
other former colonial metropoles is that
we do not have
any monuments for victims of the
colonization or
heroes of anti-colonial resistance
anvetzi is collecting her son she wants
him to learn
as much as possible about his family's
history
her own mother still remembers the
brutal reality of colonial rule
in the mid 20th century back in africa
our parents didn't want us to see them
being treated badly
they would tell us not to come close
but i was curious i would hide and ask
myself
why people were being hit
and one day i asked my dad if he'd been
hit
he said yes and told me that he'd been
punished
because he didn't have enough money to
pay the taxes
on betsy knows that many parents of
congolese descent do not like to share
unpleasant memories but for her son
and the generations to come she feels
transparency
is the best way forward
[Music]
all those family secrets are passed down
from generation to generation
and it weighs on people but when you say
things clearly
this allows future generations to cope
with the past
so they don't become victims of what
remains in our collective consciousness
the situation is
the exact opposite is what you find in
colonial art
a glorification of this time in the
africa museum in brussels
most of the colonial art has been
confined to a small room
in the basement but as long as people
from that era are still alive wedzie
feels
that's not enough to them is just
oh look at our past how glorious it was
maybe we should put all the statues away
from them for the moment
maybe wait that those people disappear
and then show them again but with
another message
and just with the real message that
the belgium didn't bring civilization to
congo belgium came to
steal everywhere you go in belgium
you come across colonial monuments
confronting the reality of this past is
a painful but
crucial process wetzi feels now a first
step
has been made